you think David was mad at us and he was
really bummed at our performance like a
parent he felt it yeah yeah the way you
shook my hand made me sad give me your
hand
no not mine because mine are always
sweaty but it doesn't matter okay do you
think your sweaty hand is worse than old
sushi fingers over yeah here we go
okay right this way you're me oh yeah
hey man thanks hey thanks a lot good job
oh you're out bro he was like yeah
you're out I know basically gave you a
finger poke he wanted to put your hand
out he wanted to go like this he wanted
to go get that guy but I wanted to go
get I like to say something about him
though III on a [ __ ] not only that and
einem to be I mean if you mean like him
and not like whatever I'm I'm sure most
people like him but who doesn't [ __ ] him
like that guy I know but he is literally
one of my favorites he's [ __ ] nice
guys so funny that's why I did have a
question could something like this
jeopardize a friendship let's say you
were doing a show and your friend just
absolutely bombed doesn't matter oh here
well here's the most important part of
this it's not a real it's not gonna air
this is just for insight it's for okay
okay so the good news it like bobbi and
i if it was gonna air oh if we wouldn't
be human I would adopted died gone I
would assume so so first we would like
try to steal the tape mm-hmm give me the
tape give me the tape now I mean the
tape I'm burning it I'm burning good
promise for a movie trying to steal I'm
so bad just the whole thing is about you
trying to steal the tape
- in 48 hours or 48 hours right you
gotta get them you have to get the tape
yeah that's really funny that's really
fun and they've shipped it across town
to this other place that you need to get
to and all these obstacles get in your
way
yeah yeah that's pretty cool it's a
really good idea yeah no actually you
know it is sometimes they shoot stuff to
New York and have to wait to air it
there you know they like yeah yeah yeah
I shoot and it holds it yeah we have to
go to New York to stop the roller server
so yeah it's a road movie yeah it was
kind of like that's like similarly not
similar but it's the idea of like
airhead so if like do you remember
airhead they have to get their tape on
the air yeah and then they've
jeopardized their entire lives and now
they're like gunpoint fighting with the
cops like the king of comedy with Rupert
pumpkin as De Niro not as many people
are familiar without have you know
no he made me watch it Robert it's a
Scorsese movie
where Robert De Niro plays a stand-up oh
I know the movie right I know the movie
yes he hijacks the Johnny Carson which
is Richard yeah Louis in it yeah just so
he can get a spot on show so he said he
was gonna kill him yeah if you don't put
me onto the air has any kill on his show
yeah and then later he becomes a big
star that's a good lesson that's good
because you want to steal it so because
it's a career ending right yeah it's
good and your career yeah but at the end
though they do era in this movie I'm
gonna becomes a hit right we wanted all
of it so all of it is may be a moot talk
about this how that's really funny how
about you go you go there and they you
don't get it in time and end up airing
it and it bombs even harder than you
remember like you thought okay but this
joke was at least okay where would you
see it like I'm racing on like right by
us
maybe I'm square in electronics store
where are they have 15 TVs right yeah
yeah there's people hovering around
right yeah watching you bomb in Times
Square on that big screen and they just
start booing the whole Times Square
boost the screen yeah yeah it's against
the window right and they turn around
and they see you and then they chase you
to kill you you should kill yourself
yeah they're gonna kill you a guy shocks
kill em for comedy yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what I felt like yeah it was
banned let me clarify it was bad both
Bobby and I extremely respect David
Spade I'm very appreciative we had a
good time being with friends we were sad
we didn't perform oh that's what this is
all that's what it nobody's fault but
ours we didn't listen they asked us they
do a [ __ ] the ask Dave asked us to
because we I have good chemistry with
Dave
he knows that usually I'm funny and he
sit the thing with Andrew because we're
trying to help him
you know shape this shelf yeah yeah
right and what we did today didn't help
I did I did him it was a disservice
yeah it sucks and I'm gonna blame you
for it for not good I didn't read the
thing it's not my fault okay it's not my
fault it's not all with all the way my
fault it's uh my fault the other part is
you did jokes on your own and they still
didn't go over well
No you know you definitely did some of
your own and of theirs and it didn't do
well not just me I know I know I just
don't like the way you're saying and
Esther and Esther had a few very cute
jokes and they didn't applaud even
applause break Oh Vince he got up
they're so funny she is no kitchen she
here - she figured out the balance not
only did she what she just shooted the
way she was sitting on the chair he put
her legs up we should put her legs up
she's kind of curled up in like a
comfortable position yeah and she just
was like speaking freely we're him and I
sweat that's right and then what I did
get a laugh what did I do
stood up I stood up and screamed as long
as I could what idly yeah they liked it
though they did like it yeah yeah but I
got a laugh I didn't see was a
legitimate laugh it was and I stood up
and that was that thing I said to was
something I never even thought about cuz
he goes I wasn't even gonna say
something about that topic uh-huh but at
the end he goes what's your thing and I
had to make something up kind of but it
worked in a world no he's the Eric
Griffin story oh that's what the
airplane story there was an airplane
story there's Cam Newton's as a
quarterback for the Carolina Panthers
and he was seated on accident in coach
instead of first-class so he asked the
guy in first-class seat said can I have
that seat for $1,500 in the first-class
guy said no and then we talked about on
this thing and they said the only
airline stories and Bobby said well I
poked it with a wooden Dubai in there oh
yeah I got a laugh I want the middle C
yeah yeah yeah it did get a laugh I see
I think it did yeah yeah yeah but um but
the problem was not a strong enough
laugh just nothing was strong enough
none of the laughter David got good
laughs good laughs and rate laughs yep
and then we I just you know I feel were
there Adam he gets there too I just feel
like I dropped the ball and disappointed
everybody and I'm sorry if you have
anything to do with [ __ ] up mean and
or very sorry about it usually we're on
you know how funny was to be if this
ended our career I feel like we didn't
we're not gonna air it but we are gonna
make sure nobody works with you guys
ever again what do we do well you know
what you did you did so [ __ ] bad that
you first of all to fig newtons out of
the Wardrobe and you didn't even ask
they weren't yours you didn't cut the
hair and make up on time you showed up a
little bit late and you bomb miserably
you were late I wasn't here to wake him
up
it's always a problem a little bit I
guess what what you're out of Hollywood
bud
say good night pack up your stuff and
truth man this podcast is cancelled and
so is everything else you're ever gonna
do if that's the case you're done you
know I've thought about what would
happen in certain situations where I get
in a car accident I think my throat gets
[ __ ] up I can't talk anymore think
about that [ __ ]
well I threatened him that that's his
future if he doesn't get healthy yeah
well that may always say you're gonna
stroke out and guess what you you think
that you're just gonna die no you're
gonna live 20 miserable years unable to
speak but you don't understand you're
right he's terrible it'll be terrible
yeah that would be terrible but but I
have my life already planned out in case
that happened okay what is it it
involves involves I have to it sounds
like it's not planned out at all it is
I'm telling you okay I just talks a lot
sometimes yeah but you're thinking about
what it is you would know you would know
you don't know you're do you have how do
you call it like an exit strategy no
advance directives Oh like do you know
like what someone is gonna do do you we
do CPR is it a do not resuscitate do you
know any of that what do you mean when I
did kill myself advanced directive no
what would we do if you get in a coma
can she pull the plug
yes over how what's the span who has a
power of it degree who has a power of
attorney your brother you will but I I
didn't know that see I'm giving you the
no no it has to be on paper just on this
part of it in one game in a coma for one
day and you're like pull away no way I
gotta see your you know your brainwaves
see if it's still active listen if I can
move my fingers right if I can use my
fingers yeah if I can do this mm-hmm
just put my hand in my face like this
hmm
cuz this is where I this I need this or
drink the whiskey mm-hmm right I need
this to smoke the marijuana you don't do
I don't do anything good but that's what
I would do yeah so I'm gonna call my
right no a stroke and I can't move my
body you have to put something here
I mean heroin or something right and I
do it and then with this hand if I can
use I could play you know an RPG or
something that's true I live like that
and I have enough money saved I think
I'll be fine
[Music]